NOW IN SESSION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF
A QUORUM THE SERGEANT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS MADAM CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ACOSTA AGUIAR-CURRY ALLEN
ARAMBULA. BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW. BLOOM.
BONTA. BROUGH.
BURKE
CABALLERO CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU. CHAVEZ
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU CHOI. KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DALLY.
DALY
EGGMAN FLORA.
FONG.
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN. GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GRAY.
GRAYSON
HARPER HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KALAGER-DOVE.
KILEY.
LACKEY LEVINE LIMON OWN.
LOW. MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY. MEDINA MELENDEZ
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA.
REYES RODRIGUEZ
RUBIO.
SALAS
SANTIAGO STEINORTH STONE.
THURMOND AND.
TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON.
WEBER. WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS PLEASE REPORT TO THE
FLOOR SO WE CAN BEGIN SESSION
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S A VOCATION WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR GUEST CHAPLAIN
IMAM MOHAMED ABDUL AZIZ MAMA'S
HE'S.
ALMIGHTY GOD.
I STAND BEFORE YOU HUMBLE AND
HOPEFUL.
FASTING IN THE BLESSED MONTH OF
RAMADAN.
SEEKING YOUR LOVE FORGIVENESS.
AND SUPPORT.
LORD GRANT US GOOD IN THIS WORLD
AND GOOD IN THE LIFE TO COME.
KEEP US SAFE FROM TORMENT AND
HUMILIATION.
LORD.
TAKE IS NOT TO TASK IF WE
FORGET.
FALL INTO AIR.
LORD LET NOT OUR HEARTS DEVIATE
FROM THE TRUTH AFTER YOU HAVE
GUIDED US.
AND BESTOW UPON US MERCY FROM
YOUR GRACE.
GRANT US THAT WHICH YOU HAVE
PROMISED TO US BY YOUR
MESSENGERS.
AND SAVE US FROM SHAME ON THE
DAY OF JUDGMENT.
LORD.
YOU TRULY KNOW ALL THAT WE MAY
HIDE IN OUR HEARTS AS WELL AS
ALL THAT WE BRING INTO THE OPEN.
FOR NOTHING WHATEVER BE IT ON
EARTH OR IN HEAVEN. REMAINS
HIDDEN FROM YOU.
LORD GRANT THAT OUR FAMILIES AND
LOVED ONES BE A COMFORT TO OUR
EYES.
AND GIVE US THE GRACE TO LEAD
THE RIGHTEOUS.
LORD BRING SUCCESS AND
PROSPERITY.
TO THIS BEAUTIFUL LAND.
AND BRING PEACE TO OUR BROTHERS
AND SISTERS IN THE MIDDLE EAST.
MAKE US INSTRUMENTS
IN RESOLVING THEIR PLIGHT AND
EASING THEIR PAIN.
WE ASK YOU LORD TO GUIDE OUR
LAWMAKERS TO DO THAT WHICH IS
RIGHT FOR OUR STATE.
AND MAKE THE ONLY CONSIDERATION
RELEVANT TO THEM TO BE
RIGHTEOUSNESS.
AND THE BENEFIT.
OF ARE PEOPLE.
I MEAN.
THANK YOU ASKING TO REMAIN
STANDING AND TWO AND A JOINED US
IN THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL.
HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE.
MEMBERS ATTENTION TO THE COLORS
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE
ATTIC.
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND HILLARY RODHAM.
YEAH XIN.
IT IS.
ANY TAXES.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY MAY SECOND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE SEMI MET AT
SEVEN A. M.. ANIMAL TONY
THURMOND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS OF THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS OF
PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTIONS AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES
FROM THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
AT TODAY'S ABSENCES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MELISSA MELENDEZ
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIGUEL SANTIAGO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALBERT EUGENE.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN NAY TO ALLOW
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR.
TO ALLOW ISSUES ME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALDRON HAD GUESTS AND
AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR
TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER THANK YOU I
ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY WILL FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE. TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
AND DAVID CHIU TO SPEAK ON
ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX PLEASE WITHDRAW
AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SIX YOU
GARCIA FROM THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AND ORDERED THE BILL
TO SECOND READING FILE THE BILL
IS NOT FISCAL. THE CLERK WILL
NOTE.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE REFER THE FOLLOWING BILLS
COMMITTEE S. B. FIVE THIRTY NINE
DELEON FROM THE HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
TO THE ASSEMBLY TODAY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES YOU'RE
READY FOR YOUR YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
IN THE GALLERY TODAY ARE
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE CITY OF
GRAND TERRACE FROM MY DISTRICT.
MAYOR DARCY MAC THE BONE.
CITY MANAGER G. HAROLD DUFFY.
LIEUTENANT DOUG WALL FROM
DECEMBER TO DINO SHERIFF'S
OFFICE.
AND JAMES WESTERN PRINCIPLE OF
GRAND TERRACE HIGH SCHOOL.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN CONGRATULATING
THEM ON THE FORTIETH ANNIVERSARY
OF THE FOUNDING OF GRAND TERRACE
AND HELP ME WELCOME THEM HERE
TODAY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY
YOUR READ YOUR RECOGNIZE
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I.
WANT TO. RECOGNIZE THE EIGHTH
GRADE CLASS
FROM BIG VALLEY HIGH SCHOOL AND
I WANT TO YOU DIRECTLY TO KNOW.
THAT EVERY YEAR.
THEY SELL SEES CANDY IN THE BOX
ACADIE THAT COMES TO YOUR
OFFICE.
IPURCHASED FROM THE AP CLASSES
THERE FUND RAISER SO THEY CAN
COME TO THE CAPITOL AND I WANT
TO. ACKNOWLEDGE THAT SHIRLEY
WEBER ALWAYS DONATES
A TO THEM TO HELP BUT THEY GET
YEARS OF THE CLASSES RIGHT
APPEAR ALL SEVEN OR EIGHT OF
THEM.
WITH THEIR TEACHERS
SEC WELCOME.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE OUT OF
ORDER TO ITEM FIFTY TO ACR TWO
OH FIVE MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO A FIVE BY SOME A MEMBER
WALDRON AND OTHERS BILL TO TO
THE CAL FIRE FIRE FIGHTER CORY
EVERSON MEMORIAL HIGHWAY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALDRON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
WHILE OUR STATE WAS BEING
BUFFETED BY WILDFIRES MY
DISTRICT WAS IMPACTED BY THE
LILAC FIRE AS WELL.
AND THE LOSS OF SO MANY HOMES.
WE RECEIVED WORD OF THE PASSING
A FIRE ENGINEER CORPS YOU DAVID
IVERSON RESIDENT OF MY DISTRICT.
I RISE TO RECOGNIZE THE
TREMENDOUS CONTRIBUTION OF CAL
FIRE ENGINEER IVERSON. BY
DEDICATING STATE ROUTE FIFTEEN
BETWEEN INTERSTATE SEVENTY EIGHT
AND VIA RANCHO PARKWAY. AS THE
CAL FIRE FIREFIGHTER COREY
IVERSON MEMORIAL FREEWAY.
MISTER IVERSON WAS A CAL FIRE
SAN DIEGO UNITS FIRE APPARATUS
ENGINEER.
RESIDENT OF MY DISTRICT.
LOVING HUSBAND.
FATHER.
BROTHER.
A MAN OF FAITH.
WHO DIED DECEMBER FOURTEENTH
WHILE BRAVELY BATTLING THE
DEVASTATING THOMAS WILDFIRE?
HE WAS THIRTY TWO. WITH AN
AMAZING BEAUTIFUL WIFE ASHLEY.
SWEET DAUGHTER EVEY AND BABY ON
THE WAY WHO IS NOW A PRECIOUS
NEWBORN TWO WEEKS OLD. TAYLOR
IV.
HIS MOTHER FATHER STEPFATHER
BROTHER LUKE.
SISTER AND EXTENDED FAMILY MISS
HIM AND CELEBRATE HIS LIFE.
AS AN ORANGE GLOW EN HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATE.
HE IS NOW OUR VERY OWN HOMETOWN
HERO.
KOREA IVERSON WAS IN ESCONDIDO
RESIDENT. AND DISCOVERED HIS
PASSION FOR FIRE SERVICE BY
FOLLOWING IN HIS UNCLE'S
FOOTSTEPS
IT WAS A STEADFAST AND
COMMITTED.
TO BEING THE BEST FIREFIGHTER HE
CAN BE AND ALWAYS STRIVING TO
LEARN AND DO MORE EVEN BECOMING
ONE OF THOSE FRONTLINE
FIREFIGHTERS DROPPING FROM A
HELICOPTER ON THE EDGE OF THE
SURGING FLAMES.
IVERSON JOIN CAL FIRE.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE F. THE
WORKING FOR THE HARMONY GROVE
FIRE DEPARTMENT FOR SEVEN YEARS.
BUT ON A MORE IMPORTANT NOTE.
CORY WAS A MAN OF FAITH WHO
DEVOTED HIS LIFE TO SHARING THE
LOVE OF JESUS.
HE WAS A GREAT FRIEND TO MANY
AND INSPIRED OTHERS TO ALWAYS
STRIVE FOR SOMETHING GREATER.
AND LEAD BY EXAMPLE AND SHARING
LIFE WITH HIS BROTHERS IN CAL
FIRE.
WHEN I ATTENDED HIS SERVICE WITH
SO MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE ON
THE FLOOR. THE AMOUNT OF SUPPORT
FROM HIS BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN
THE FIRE SERVICE WAS PALPABLE.
THAT THE LOVE THEY HAD FOR HIM
AND THE LEADERSHIP THAT HE
ALWAYS SHOWED AND HOW PASSIONATE
HE WAS FOR THIS SERVICE WAS
EVIDENT.
FROM FROM HIS BOOK TITLED SIMPLY
SIMPLY HAVEN'T.
OF PERMISSION TO READ.
MADAM SPEAKER WITHOUT OBJECTION.
RANDY ALCORN STATES QUOTE.
MEANWHILE WE ARE ON THIS IS
DYING EARTH.
CAN RELAX FOR A LOT OF THE ONES
OR IN THE PRESENCE OF CHRIST.
AS THE APOSTLE PAUL TELLS US
THOUGH WE NATURALLY GRIEVANCE
LOSING LOVED ONES WE ARE NOT TO
GRIEVE. LIKE THE REST OF MEN WHO
HAVE NO HOPE.
OUR PARTING IS NOT THE END OF
OUR RELATIONSHIP ONLY AN
INTERRUPTION.
WE HAVE NOT LOST THEM BECAUSE WE
KNOW WHERE THEY ARE.
THEY EXPERIENCING THE JOY OF
CHRIST'S PRESENCE IN THE PLACE
SO WONDERFUL THE CHRIST HIMSELF
CALLED THE PARADISE.
SO MY COLLEAGUES I AM HONORED ON
BEHALF OF CAL FIRE AND THE
IVERSON FAMILY.
TO PRESENT ACR TOOL. AND ASK FOR
THE FIRST ROLE TO BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON.
THANK YOU.
AND LIKE TO JOIN MY COLLEAGUE
FROM ESCONDIDO. AND.
SPEAKING ABOUT THE BRAVERY AND
THE COMMITMENT OF COREY IVERSON.
AS A REPRESENTATIVE WHO
REPRESENTS THE COMMUNITIES
FILLMORE SANTA PAULA VENTURE
SANTA BARBARA MONTECITO
CARPINTERIA.
ALL AREAS IMPACTED BY THE THOMAS
FIRE.
THE IDEA THAT CORY IVERSON IS A
HOMETOWN HERO RESONATES WITH US.
IT'S NOT JUST FOR THE COMMUNITY
OF ESCONDIDO. IT'S FOR THE
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
HE EXEMPLIFIED UNTIL THE VERY
END.
THE COMMITMENT BRAVERY AND
UNSELFISHNESS.
OF WHICH SO MANY OF OUR FIGHTERS
EXEMPLIFIED DURING CALIFORNIA'S
LARGEST WILDFIRE.
IT WAS ONE OF THE MOST
DEVASTATING FIRES IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY.
AND KORI IVERSON WILL ALWAYS BE
REMEMBERED AS A HERO WHO LAID
DOWN HIS LIFE
TO PROTECT THOSE AROUND HIM.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER REQUEST
TO SPEAK MEADOW QUIRK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE FOR CALL AUTHORS.
I.
MEMBERS THIS RULES FOR
COAUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS RULES RECALL AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
S. ROLLERS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE FIFTY EIGHT
COAUTHORS BUT A QUICK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE ON.
THE RESOLUTION IS FISCAL MOVE
TAKING A ROLL CALL VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM COURT PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TELLING THE VOTES EYES
SIXTY TWO NO ZERO THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED RETURNING NOW TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON FOR HER
GAS INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. IT IS MY HONOR TO
INTRODUCE KOREA IVERSON'S
BROTHER.
LUKE IVERSON.
ALONG WITH CAL FIRE CHIEF CURTIS
BROWN.
WHO IS HERE IN HONOR OF THIS
RESOLUTION
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE
AHEAD? ON THE AGENDA.
TO ITEM ONE SEVENTEEN AS SEE ARE
ONE TWENTY SEVEN MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
TWENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR PELL
BILLETED IN NATIONAL MENTAL
HEALTH AWARENESS MONTH.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
GOOD MORNING MISS SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I RISE TO PRESENT STR ONE TWENTY
SEVEN DECLARING MAY AS MENTAL
HEALTH AWARENESS MONTH.
MENTAL ILLNESS IS ONE OF THE
LEADING CAUSES OF DISABILITY IN
THE UNITED STATES AFFECTING ONE
OUT OF EVERY FOUR FAMILIES.
AMONG CALIFORNIA ADULTS ONE IN
TWENTY SUFFERS FROM SERIOUS
MENTAL HEALTH ILLNESS THAT MAKES
IT DIFFICULT TO CARRY OUT MAJOR
LIFE EXPECTED BODIES.
THE RATE HIM AMONG CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN IS EVEN HIGHER.
ONE IN THIRTEEN SUFFERS FROM
MENTAL ILLNESS THAT LIMITS HIS
OR HER ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
DAILY. ACTIVITIES.
NEARLY TWO THIRDS OF ALL THESE
PEOPLE WITH DIAGNOSABLE MENTAL
ILLNESS DO NOT RECEIVE MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT DO THE STIGMA.
RESOURCES AN ADEQUATE DIAGNOSIS
OR NO DIAGNOSIS.
WITHOUT A DOUBT WE HAVE MADE
SIGNIFICANT STRIDES SINCE THE
PASSAGE OF MENTAL HEALTH.
SERVICES ACT HOWEVER THE WORK IS
NOT DONE.
WE CAN AND MUST CONTINUE TO
FIGHT AGAINST THE STIGMA THAT IS
KEEPING TOO MANY PEOPLE FROM
ACCEPT ASSESSING ACCESSING
MENTAL HEALTH. CARE THEY NEED.
WE ALSO FIT ARE FACING A
CRITICAL SHORTAGE OF TRAINED
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AND
INCREASING ACCESS TO THIS
WORKFORCE IS AN IMPORTANT PART
OF THE SOLUTION.
EACH OF YOU HAS RECEIVED A
VIBRANT GREEN TIRES SCARF AND A
PIN AND ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
WHERE THE SYMBOL IN SUPPORT OF
MENTAL HEALTH. AWARENESS MONTH.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK AN AYE VOTE
ON SCR ONE TWENTY SEVEN
ANNOUNCED THAT THE FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY
AS A MEMBER OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION TO
OFFER MY STRONG SUPPORT. FOR
RECOGNIZING MAN'S MENTAL HEALTH
AWARENESS MONTH.
SO WE CAN TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO DISCUSS THE SERVICES THAT WE
AS A STATE NEED TO PROVIDE.
MENTAL HEALTH AND MANY RELATED
PRESSING CHALLENGES THAT
CALIFORNIA FACES TODAY.
IN A RECENT STUDY BY UCLA
RESEARCHERS FOUND THAT IN THE
CURRENT POLITICAL CLIMATE FIFTY
ONE PERCENT OF TEACHERS
SUPPORTED. MORE STUDENTS
EXPERIENCING HIGH LEVELS OF
STRESS
AND ANXIETY.
THERE PRESS REPORT AN INCREASE
IN RACE RELATED SOCIO POLITICAL
TRAUMA.
BECAUSE OF OUR CURRENT POLITICAL
CLIMATE.
TOO MANY OF OUR MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES IMMIGRANTS REFUGEES
MINORITIES SUFFER DISPARITIES
AND THE ABILITY TO RECOGNIZE
DIAGNOSE AND ADDRESS MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES.
WE SERVE THE PEOPLE AND THERE IS
NO GREATER RESPONSIBILITY AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ADVOCATE FOR
THEIR LIBERTY AND FOR THEIR
HEALTH.
MENTAL HEALTH IS REAL.
COMPLICATED.
BUT IT IS IMPACTFUL.
IT'S INCUMBENT UPON US AND THIS
GOVERNING BODY TO REFLECT THE
TRUTH IN OUR ACTIONS.
BY TALKING ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH
WE CAN HELP REDUCE THE STIGMA
THAT PREVENT SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS.
FROM SEEKING THE SERVICES THEY
DESERVE ANSEL RIGHTFULLY NEED.
FROM VETERANS SUFFERING FROM
PTSD.
DEPRESSION TO THE UNDOCUMENTED
FAMILY FACING FEAR OF FAMILY
SEPARATION.
TO THE TRAUMA EXPERIENCED BY
YOUNG PEOPLE SIMPLY TRYING TO GO
TO SCHOOL AND GET AN EDUCATION
AND LIVE THROUGH A SCHOOL
SHOOTING.
THERE IS SO MUCH MORE THAT WE
CAN DO.
IF ONE WORD COMES TO MIND AS WE
DISCUSS MENTAL HEALTH AWARENESS
FOR THIS MONTH IS THE WORD.
COMPASSION.
I THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
WINTERS FOR BRINGING THIS TO THE
FLOOR AND I STRONGLY URGE I VOTE
FOR. THIS RESOLUTION THINKING.
THANK YOU SOMEONE MEMBER
CARILLO.
AS A MEMBER MATHIS YOU
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
MENTAL HEALTH AWARENESS MONTH.
MANY OF YOU KNOW I AM THE FIRST
MILLENNIAL COMBAT VETERAN WITH A
PURPLE HEART TO STATE OFFICE.
WHAT YOU DON'T KNOW IS WHEN I
RETURNED HOME?
I WAS GIVEN A BAG OF PILLS AND
TOLD GO HOME AND TAKE THESE.
I HAD A STRUGGLE HAD TO GO
THROUGH WHAT'S KNOWN AS
COGNITIVE RETRAINING THERAPY
WHERE YOU HAVE TO RE LEARN HOW
TO LEARN.
I WAS TOLD THAT I COULDN'T DO
ANYTHING.
YET I'VE I'VE RISEN.
IN BECOMING ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN
ONE OF YOUR COLLEAGUES.
MANY VETERANS GO ONE NOTICE.
MENTAL HEALTH IS A HUGE PROBLEM
FOR OUR VETERANS FOR OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OUR MEN AND WOMEN
WHO ARE FIRST RESPONDERS.
OUR YOUNG CHILDREN IN POVERTY.
MENTAL HEALTH IS HUGE.
PERMISSION TO USE A PROP.
PERMISSION GRANTED. A I'M GONNA
RAISE MY EINSTEIN TIED BECAUSE
EINSTEIN IS ONE OF THE KEY
FOUNDERS.
YOU KNOW THEY THEY TOLD HIM HE
COULDN'T DO ANYTHING HE'S BEEN
ONE OF THE GREATEST MINDS OF OUR
TIME.
MEMBERS AS WE REFLECT UPON THIS
MONTH I ASK YOU LET'S LOOK AT
THESE BUDGETS AHEAD OF US.
TO PUT THE RESOURCES AND FUNDING
BACK INTO MENTAL HEALTH.
LET'S HELP THESE PEOPLE THRIVE
IN OUR SOCIETY.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THEY CAN.
SO LET'S HELP THEM SUCCEED.
LET'S BE AWARE.
AND LET'S DO THE RIGHT THING.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
I RISES UP AS A MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL AYE AS WELL AS AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
LIKE MANY OF YOU WE ALL HAD
DIFFERENT PATHS TO GET HERE AND
A AT SOME POINT I THOUGHT I
CAN'T KEEP WORKING WITH PEOPLE
ON AN INDIVIDUAL AND A FAMILY
BASIS IF WE DON'T LOOK AT THE
ACTUAL POLICIES THAT IMPACT THE
WORLD THAT PEOPLE TRY TO LIVE
IN.
AS SO AS MEMBERS AS AS PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT THIS BUDGET LETS MAKE
SURE THAT WE ACTUALLY PUT OUR
MONEY WHERE OUR VALUES ARE WE
NEED TO HAVE SOCIAL WORKERS IN
SCHOOLS. WE KNOW THAT AMOUNT OF
VOTE THAT THE TRAUMA THAT KIDS
COME TO SCHOOL WITH AND THEN IT
IMPACT THEIR ABILITY TO LEARN
IMPACTS OUR ABILITY TO FOCUS. IS
HUGE AND IF WE HAVE MORE MENTAL
HEALTH WERE AT AT AT SCHOOLS
WILL HAVE LESS PROBLEMS LATER
BUT WHEN WE LOOK AT THE HOMELESS
ISSUE RIGHT NOW YES WE HAVE A
LOT OF WE PASSED PROP SIXTY
THREE. BUT THERE IS A LOT OF
MONEY SITTING OUT THERE FOR
PREVENTION WHEN NOW WE'RE AT THE
POINT WE NEED REALLY SERIOUS
MONEY FOR INTERVENTION. OUT WE
NEED MORE PSYCHIATRIC BEDS WE
NEED MORE FUNDING FOR A.
HOMELESS ISSUES THERE IS A.
ALMOST ANYTHING WE TALK ABOUT IS
IMPACTED BY ISSUES AROUND MENTAL
HEALTH DEPRESSION.
TRAUMA ABUSE ALL OF THOSE THINGS
GO TOGETHER THAT END UP COSTING
US A WHOLE LOT MORE IN THE LONG
RUN UNCHECKED THEN IF WE DO A
LOT MORE ON THE FRONT END.
BUT WHILE WE'RE DOING THAT MONEY
ON THE FRONT END WE CANNOT
FORGET THAT WE NEED THE BASKET
ON THE BACK INTO TO BE ABLE TO
HELP PEOPLE WHO ARE NOW IN IN
DESPERATE NEED. WHOSE FAMILY
SUFFER WITH THEM I HAVE A A A
NEIGHBOR WHO LIVED BEHIND WHO
JUST RETIRED AFTER THIRTY YEARS
AS A.
A NURSE
I AND I BEGIN TO HEAR NOISES
COMING FROM HER HOUSE AND SHE'S
HAD TO MOVE HER FORTY SEVEN YEAR
OLD SON HOME WITH SEVERE
PSYCHOSIS.
IT'S ABOUT THAT'S THAT'S HER
RETIREMENT IS WHICH IS TRYING TO
DEAL WITH AS SHE'S TRYING TO
FIND PLACEMENTS FOR HIM IT IS
ONGOING IT IMPACTS FAMILIES IN
YOUR FAMILY I'M SURE IN YOUR
NEIGHBORHOODS AND ALL AROUND. OF
MEMBERS AS WE WEAR GREEN AND AS
WE VOTE LET'S NOT GO HOME AND
FORGET ABOUT THE WORK THAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE EVERY SINGLE DAY WE
HAVE OPPORTUNITIES TO MAKE
THINGS BETTER FOR PEOPLE.
BAKE YOU A SIMILAR AGAR CURRY.
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
CLOTHES.
SIMPLY ASK FOR YOUR I'VE.
YOUR QUESTION CO AUTHORS ON THIS
RESOLUTION YES SIR YES SIR. A
VERY GOOD.
QUICKLY IS OPEN THE ROLE
MEMBERS THIS AGUIAR-CURRY IS
ASKING FOR CO AUTHORS ON HER
RESOLUTION.
MEMBERS THIS IS PROKOFIEV'S.
LOCAL CLOTHES THE ROLE THEIR
SIXTY EIGHT CO AUTHORS.
THAT WILL ALLOW US TO MOVE TO A
VOICE VOTE ALL THOSE IN FAVOR OF
THE RESOLUTION PLEASE SIGNIFY BY
SAYING AYE. AYE THOSE OPPOSED
SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
IS I GOT HER YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR INTRODUCTIONS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO
INTRODUCE GUESTS.
BETTER HERE IN THE GALLERY TODAY
WEARING THEIR BRIGHT GREEN TO
RECOGNIZE ME AS MENTAL HEALTH
AWARENESS MONTH.
WE HAVE REPRESENTATIVES FROM.
AND PLEASE STAND THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE FOR MENTAL ILLNESS THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE EACH MINE
MATTERS MENTAL HEALTH AMERICA OF
CALIFORNIA. THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES AND THE CALIFORNIA
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
AUTHORITY.
LEFT THAT LET'S GIVE THEM A
CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY WELCOME
.
MEMBERS WILL MOVE TO THE TOP OF
THE FILE.
QUICKLY PLEASE INTRODUCE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY THREE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT BY FAMILY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
AND OTHERS AND ACT LIKE WATER.
THIS FRIEDMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
AMENDMENTS MADE.
TO A. B. SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT THE
SENATE DID THE FOLLOWING.
REMOVE THE PROVISIONS REGARDING
URBAN WATER MANAGEMENT PLANS IN
PLACE THOSE IN SP SIX OH SIX
WHICH WAS VOTED OFF THIS FLOOR
ON MONDAY. INCORPORATED THE
PROVISIONS REGARDING
AGRICULTURAL MANAGEMENT PLANS
THAT WERE IN AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN WHICH PASSED THIS FOR WITH
A BIPARTISAN VOTE ON MAY THIRTY
FIRST TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
REQUIRED THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES TO
ADOPT WATER EFFICIENCY
REGULATIONS.
REQUIRES GW ARE TO RECOMMEND AND
THE BOARD TO ADOPT APPROPRIATE
VARIANCES FOR UNIQUE USES THAT
CAN HAVE A MATERIAL EFFECT ON AN
URBAN RETAILER WATER SUPPLIERS
URBAN WATER USE OBJECTIVE.
LAST YEAR AFTER THE MOST SEVERE
DROUGHT IN MODERN HISTORY I AND
OTHERS IN THIS HOUSE BEGIN A
PROCESS OF MAKING LONG TERM
WATER USE IN CALIFORNIA MORE
SUSTAINABLE.
THIS BILL AND ITS COMPANION S.
B. SIX OH SIX INSURERS THAT OUR
STATE WILL BE MORE PREPARED TO
HANDLE FUTURE WATER SHORTAGES.
IT IS A FRAMEWORK FOR DROUGHT
RESILIENCY IN THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY I'M FOR WATER USE
EFFICIENCY.
FRAMEWORK BUILT ON HUNDREDS OF
HOURS OF MEETINGS SIGNIFICANT
COMPROMISES AND FINDING COMMON
UNDERSTANDING AND GOALS.
THE BILL'S INCLUDE VARIANCES
ALLOWANCES FOR SPECIAL AND
UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES RATHER THAN
TRYING TO FIT A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL APPROACH ACROSS THE STATE.
GROUPS AS DIVERSE AS CALIFORNIA
MISCIBLE YOU WHAT MISS MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION AN RTC.
THE SIERRA NEVADA BREWING
COMPANY AND WATER USE CALIFORNIA
ALONG WITH MANY WATER AGENCIES
ALL SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION. IT
HAS BEEN A LONG AND COMPLICATED
PROCESS BUT PASSAGE OF AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT WILL SET US
ON THE RIGHT PATH FORWARD. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU IS FRIEDMAN ETCETERA
GARCIA YOUR RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES.
MUCH AS WE DISCUSSED EARLIER
THIS WEEK ON S. B. SIX ALL SIX.
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT IS A
PRODUCT OF SUBSTANTIAL WORK BY
MANY OF OUR COLLEAGUES HERE ON
THIS FLOOR.
THESE BILLS MOVE US FORWARD IN
OUR WATER CONSERVATION AND DROP
PLANNING EFFORTS.
TOGETHER THESE BILLS REPRESENT
THE LEGISLATIVE EFFORT TO
ADDRESS LONG TERM WATER
CONSERVATION AND DROUGHT.
AS WE DISCUSSED THIS WAS A LONG
AND SOMETIMES A BIT PAINFUL
PROCESS.
BUT AT THE END.
WE DO SEE THAT MANY WATER
AGENCIES ARE NOW POINT FROM
OPPOSITION TO JOINING SOME CASES
SUPPORTING THE PACKAGE OF THESE
TWO BILLS. I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR WORK ON
THESE BILLS IN ANCHORAGE
ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER GARCIA MS RUBIO
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB WHAT
SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT I DON'T
THINK THE AUTHOR AND ALL THE
REST OF MY COLLEAGUES FOR THE.
BELONG.
PAINFUL WORK THAT WE DID THE
LAST YEAR AND A HALF AND I SAID
EARLIER THERE'S A.
A QUOTE IN WATER THAT SAYS
WHISKEYS FOR DRINKING WATER IS
FOR FIGHTING AND WE DID A LOT OF
BOTH. ODD THROUGHOUT THIS
PROCESS IT WAS.
AN AMAZING OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO COME TOGETHER AND HELP SOLVE
SOME OF THE.
WATER ISSUES I KNOW WE'RE NOT
THERE YET BUT THIS IS A SMALL
STEP INTO OUR FUTURE WATER
LEGISLATION THANK YOU AND WITH
BATTERY OUT ENCOURAGE YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU SOME A MEMBER RUBIO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS SIDE A FIRST OUT LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHORS AND THE
STAKEHOLDERS OF THIS BILL.
I KNOW THIS IS BEEN A LONG IN
CHALLENGING IN NEGOTIATION
PROCESS BY THANK YOU FOR TAKING
ON THIS IMPORTANT CHALLENGE.
THERE'S NO QUESTION THERE ARE
STATE'S POPULATION GROWS IN OUR
CLIMATE CONTINUES.
* CONTINUES TO CHANGE
WE MUST BE MORE BECOME MORE
EFFICIENT AND CONSUME WATER.
LESS WATER OVERALL. BED LIKE TO
REMIND THIS BODY THAT THIS IS AN
ENORMOUS STATE. AND AND ONE SIZE
FITS ALL SOLUTIONS RARELY TO MY
CONSTITUENTS JUSTICE.
THE WATER RELIABILITY SITUATION
IN MUCH OF MY DISTRICT WITH A
LOT MORE LIKE OREGON AND
WASHINGTON THAT IT DOES
SACRAMENTO LOS ANGELES OR SAN
DIEGO.
BECAUSE OF THIS WHEN THE
GOVERNOR IMPLEMENTED MANDATORY
WATER REUSE REDUCTIONS IN THE
DEPTHS OF OUR MOST RECENT OUT
DROUGHT. MUCH OF MY DISTRICT
RECEIVED EXEMPTIONS.
UNDER THIS BILL THAT FLEXIBILITY
IS TAKEN AWAY.
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY BECAUSE I BELIEVE THE
STANDARDS OUTLINED HERE
REASONABLE AND ACHIEVABLE.
I AGREE THAT IS A STATE WE MUST
WORK COLLECTIVELY TO REDUCE OUR
WATER CONSUMPTION. AND IT DID AT
THE END OF THE DAY CALIFORNIANS
ARE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER. BUT I
HOPE THAT AS THE DEPARTMENT
CONSIDERS CREATING STANDARDS FOR
OUTDOOR USE IT WILL TAKE IN YORK
AND COUNT. THE INCREDIBLE
DIVERSITY THAT EXISTS IN THIS
DAY AND DEVELOP ITS
RECOMMENDATIONS IN A MANNER THAT
TAKES INTO ACCOUNT. THE NEEDS OF
EACH COMMUNITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD.
SEEN OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM A SOME MEMBER
FRIEDMAN YOU'RE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR CLOTHES.
I JUST WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
WHO SPOKE I APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT I APPRECIATE THE I RIVER
EVERYONE'S UNDERSTANDING THAT
THIS CREATES A FRAMEWORK.
A FURTHER WORK TO COME AND THAT
IT DOES ABSOLUTELY RECOGNIZE THE
DIFFERENT CONDITIONS ACROSS THE
STATE AND SEEKS TO NOT HAVE A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH BUT
INSTEAD TO ALLOW FOR PROCESS.
FOR THOSE DIFFERENCES TO BE
RECOGNIZED WITHOUT I ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS FREEMAN AS THE
CLICK OPEN THE ROLE.
OUR MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
QUICKLY CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW
YOU VOTE EYES FORTY THREE KNOWS
TWENTY THREE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE FURTHER
DOWN THE FILE AND THE THIRD
READING TO THE ITEM NUMBER FORTY
EIGHT CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE FIFTY
FIVE WITH AMENDMENTS BY
SOMETHING NUMBER FRIEDMAN.
THIS FRIEDMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS TO AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY FIVE.
THIS AMENDMENTS WOULD DEFY THE
AT AND THIS IS THE BILL THAT
HELPS ENSURE. OPERABLE AT
EQUESTRIAN SAFETY.
IN URBAN AREAS IN LOS ANGELES
THESE AMENDMENTS WOULD DEFINE
THE RANCHO MASTER PLAN AREA
BURBANK ACCORDING TO BURBANK
GENERAL PLAN DEFINED THE
RIVERSIDE RANCHO AREA GLENDALE
ACCORDING TO GLENDALE MUNICIPAL
CODE. THIS IS A LEGALLY DEFINED
AREA KNOWN KNOWN AS THE RANCHO
MASTER PLAN AREA AN EQUESTRIAN
USE AREA IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AND GLENDALE IN BURBANK.
THESE AMENDMENTS WERE SUGGESTED
AND CRAFTED WITH THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THE AMENDMENTS AND THAT THE
BILL GO OUT OF PRINT AND BE PUT
BACK ON FILE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHRIS FRIEDMAN SEEN
OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK
ON THIS MATTER.
WE CAN TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS.
ALL MEMBERS IN FAVOR PLEASE SAY
AYE AYE THOSE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT.
THE BILL IS OUT OF PRINT MORE
BACK ON FILE
.
MOVING BACK TO FOIL ORDER WE'RE
MOVING BACK TO SECOND READING.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY EIGHTY SIX
THIRTY ONE FORTY NINE TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
SIX THIRTY TWO TWENTY THREE
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE THIRTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY ONE OH SEVEN TWENTY
ONE FIFTY TWO. TWENTY ONE SIXTY
TWO TWENTY TWO NINETY NINE
TWENTY FOUR NINETY SIX TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY TWENTY NINE EIGHTEEN
TWENTY NINE FORTY TWO THIRTY ONE
SIXTY EIGHT THIRTY TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY NINE TWENTY
SIXTY THREE. TWENTY ONE TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY ONE FORTY THREE
TWENTY ONE NINETY TWENTY THREE
NINETY TWENTY FIVE EIGHTEEN
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY SIX TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY TO. TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY NINETY FOUR TWENTY
NINE TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY FIFTY
EIGHT THIRTY ONE SEVENTY EIGHT
AND THIRTY ONE EIGHTY SEVEN.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
FILE ITEMS THIRTY SIX TO FORTY
ONE OUR CONTINUED.
ITEM FORTY TO PASS AND RETAIN
MOVING NOW TO ITEM FORTY THREE
AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY FOUR MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO SEVENTY
FOUR BY SOME A MEMBER QUIRK AND
ACTUALLY TO DIVISION OF
COMMUNITY PROPERTY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
COURTS ARE MAKING PET OWNERSHIP
DETERMINATIONS TODAY.
HOWEVER THE OUTCOMES ARE VERY
DIFFERENT BECAUSE OF A LACK OF
GUIDANCE IN CALIFORNIA LAW.
AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY FOUR
CHANGES THAT.
AB TWENTY FOUR SHE'S ME AB
TWENTY TO SEVENTY FOUR.
GIVES COURTS GUIDANCE ON HOW TO
RESOLVE PET OWNERSHIP CASES
DURING DIVORCE PROCEEDINGS.
PACIFIC COOLEY DISPELLED ALLOWS
JUDGES.
I TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION THE
CARE OF A PAT. IN DETERMINING
SOUL OR JOINT OWNERSHIP.
PETS ARE STILL CONSIDERED ART
LEGAL.
INCIDENT LEGALLY AS PROPERTY.
ARE MY OFFICE IS WORK CLOSELY
WITH THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND
AFTER TAKING THEIR SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS.
CHANGING A SHALL TO A MAY THEIR
NEUTRAL ON THIS MEASURE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SING THEIR REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY ONE NO ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM FORTY FOUR PASS AND RETAIN
MOVING TO ITEM FORTY FIVE AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY FIVE MATTER
QUICKLY ST.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
FIVE WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME
REMEMBER DAVID CHIU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO YOUR
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
AMENDMENTS IN AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY FIVE A BILL THAT WOULD
ALLOW. AN INDIVIDUAL ENGAGE IN
LITIGATION TO PROCEED
ANONYMOUSLY UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES THE AMENDMENTS
INCORPORATE A NUMBER OF FACTORS
THAT CALIFORNIA COURTS HAVE
ALREADY USED IN CEILING COURT
RECORDS. AND TO APPLY THOSE
FACTORS TO A PROESS THAT THE
BILL STABBER SHARES FOR A
PLAINTIFF WHO WISHES TO PROCEED
USING A PSEUDONYM. THESE
AMENDMENTS ARE PART OF AN
ONGOING DISCUSSIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT THE MEN'S BE ADOPTED
THE BILL BE SENT OUT TO PRINT
AND BE PUT BACK ON FIVE.
THANK YOU IF THERE ARE NO
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY
SAYING AYE.
ALL OPPOSED.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED.
THE BILL IS OUT OF PRINT AND
BACK ON FILE.
ITEMS FORTY SIX AND FORTY SEVEN
PASS AND RETAIN MOVING TO ITEM
OF.
FORT FORTY NINE FIFTY FIFTY ONE
ARE PASS AND RETAIN.
FIFTY TO PASS AND. THEIR LIBERTY
DEALT WITH ITEM FIFTY TWO FIFTY
THREE PASS AND RETAIN MOVING TO
ITEM FIFTY FOUR AB TWENTY EIGHT
FIFTY THREE. MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
FIFTY THREE BY SOME A MEMBER
MEDINA AND ACTUALLY THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I PRESENT A. B.
TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY THREE.
DEVELOPMENT OF WAREHOUSES IN
CALIFORNIA HAS GROWN
TREMENDOUSLY INTEREST IN RECENT
YEARS.
IN LARGE PART DUE TO SUBSIDIES
PROVIDED BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT WAREHOUSES
AREN'T NECESSARILY BENEFITING
LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
MANY OF THE JOBS THAT
WAREHOUSES.
OUR RULING AND HIGH STRESS.
MANY OF THE JOBS ARE TEMPORARY
OR SEASONAL CAUSING EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES TO FLUCTUATE. AT
THROWING FAMILIES INTO ECONOMIC
INSTABILITY.
AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY THREE WILL
INCREASE PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY.
BEFORE APPROVING AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT TAXPAYER FUNDING
SUBSIDY FOR WAREHOUSE
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE A TALLY THE VOTES.
AYE AYES FORTY FOUR NO
SEVENTEEN.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM FIFTY FIVE PASS AND RETAIN
ITEM FIFTY SIX AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY EIGHT MEDIC QUICKLY
THREE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE TWENTY
EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME
THE MEMBER KILEY.
SO WE ARE KILEY ARE RECOGNIZED
I THINK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THESE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE CLARIFY THE
INTENT OF THE BILL TO ALLOW
ALLEGATIONS OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
BY A PERMANENT SCHOOL EMPLOYEES.
THAT ARE OLDER THAN FOUR YEARS
OLD TO BE PRESENTED IN THE
DISMISSAL HEARING IN ORDER TO
ESTABLISH A PATTERN OF
MISCONDUCT I'VE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR IVA.
SEEING NO REQUEST TO SPEAK
WITHOUT A BIT WITH A IF THERE
ARE NO OBJECTIONS WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY
SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
BILL IS OUT TO PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE.
ITEM FORTY SEVEN AB TWENTY
SEVENTY FOUR MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVENTY FOR
WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME A MEMBER
BONTA.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA YOUR
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS OF
PRESENTING AMENDMENTS TO AB
TWENTY SEVENTY FOUR WHICH
NARROW.
THE SCOPE OF THE BILL THESE
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CONCERNS RAISED BY
THE OPPOSITION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS TO SEND
THE BILL OUT TO PRINT AND BACK
ON FILE.
SEEING THEIR REQUEST TO SPEAK.
IF THERE ARE NO OBJECTIONS WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
PLEASE SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL OPPOSED.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
BILL IS BACK ON FILE AN OUT OF
PRINT.
ITEMS FIFTY EACH THEIR SIXTY ONE
PASS AND RETAIN A MOVING NOW TO
ITEM SIXTY TWO AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY SEVEN ON THE AMENDMENTS
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME A
MEMBER MCCARTY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
BRING THIS MEASURE UP FOR
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS THEIR
TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING IN
NATURE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
THEY BE AMENDED AND OUT OF PRINT
BACK ON FIVE.
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE IF
THERE ARE NO OBJECTIONS WE WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
BILL IS BACK ON FILE AND HOW TO
PRINT.
ITEM SIXTY THREE AB TWENTY ONE%
SIXTY SEVEN MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE
SIXTY SEVEN BY FAMILY MEMBER
CHAO AND ACTUALLY THE PRIVACY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
TWENTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN WITH THE
FINE DIGITAL HEALTH FEEDBACK
SYSTEM TO INCLUDE DIGITAL PILLS.
WHICH ARE PHARMACEUTICAL IS
COMBINED WITH IN JUST A BONE
MICROCHIP SENSORS THAT CAN
RECORD THE TIME LOCATION AND
QUANTITY OF DRUGS TAKEN. THE
PHYSICAL STATE OF THE PERSON
TAKING THE DRUGS SUCH AS
TEMPERATURE ACTIVITY LEVEL HEART
RATE AND RESPIRATION.
THE BILL AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
SEVEN ENSURES THAT THE
CALIFORNIA CONFIDENTIALITY OF
MEDICAL INFORMATION ACT OR CMI A
APPLIES TO INFORMATION DERIVED
FROM OR IN THE POSSESSION OF
THESE DIGITAL HEALTH FEEDBACK
SYSTEMS.
THE BILL WOULD FURTHER REQUIRED
THAT MANUFACTURE EQUIPPED THE
SYSTEMS WITH REASONABLE AND
APPROPRIATE SECURITY FEATURES.
I'VE WORKED CLOSELY WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
THE BILL MOVED THROUGH THE THREE
COMMITTEES AND WILL CONTINUE TO
DO SO GOING FORWARD WITH THAT
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN THAT NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MADAM CLERK
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE TALLY THE VOTES.
AYE AYES FORTY SEVEN NO SEVEN.
THE MOTION PASSES.
ITEM SIXTY FOUR TO SIXTY EIGHT
PASS AND RETAIN MOVING TO ITEM
SIXTY NINE AJ ARE TWENTY SEVEN
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY JACK RESOLUTION TWENTY
SEVEN BY SOME A MEMBER LOW AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO CANNABIS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW YOUR
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER AJ ARE TWENTY
SEVEN CALLS ON THE U. S.
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THE FEDERAL
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO RESPECT
CALIFORNIA'S CANNABIS LAWS.
WITH RESPECT TO THE UNWARRANTED
FEDERAL CRACKDOWN OF THAT NOT
ONLY UNDERMINES OUR STATES
AUTONOMY BUT. OF THE MISGUIDED
WASTE OF PUBLIC SAFETY
RESOURCES.
BASICALLY ASK DRIVER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY YOUR
RECOGNIZE THEY CAME OUT OF
SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION.
THE CONFLICT BETWEEN THE STATE
FEDERAL. LAW IS UNSUSTAINABLE ON
THIS ISSUE.
I'M A STRONG SUPPORTER STATES
RIGHTS ARE BELIEVE THAT
DEMOCRACY WORKS BEST WHEN IT'S
CLOSER TO THE PEOPLE.
REPEALING THE CALL MEMO
UNDERMINE STATE'S RIGHTS
RELEASED TO LESS CERTAINTY.
FOR BUSINESSES TRYING TO BE
COMPLIANT NOW RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS
MEASURE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I WRITE I TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE TODAY
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD. I GOT
INVOLVED IN CANVAS POLICY
BECAUSE OF THE INCREDIBLE
ENVIRONMENTAL DAMAGE IN MY
DISTRICT.
THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY HAS WORKED
HARD OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS
TO DEVELOP A FRAMEWORK FOR THIS
INDUSTRY. TO CREATE A PATHWAY TO
COMPLIANCE FOR BUSINESS OWNERS
THAT DO WANT TO DO THE THINGS
THE RIGHT WAY.
AT EVERY TURN WE HAVE STRIVE TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS A LEGAL
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA THAT WILL
UNDERCUT THE BLACK MARKET AND
RUN THESE BAD ACTORS OUT OF
BUSINESS.
RACK THE PERHAPS THE BIGGEST
INCENTIVE CALIFORNIA PROMISE
CANNABIS BUSINESS OWNERS IN
EXCHANGE FOR PAYING TAXES
LICENSING FEES COMPLY WITH SOME
OF THE STRICTEST PUBLIC HEALTH.
PUBLIC SAFETY ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS IN THE WORLD. IS THE
PROMISE OF LEGITIMACY IN THE
EYES OF THE LAW.
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE A FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION AND IS
THREATENING TO TREAT LEGITIMATE
TAXPAYING BUSINESS OWNERS NO
DIFFERENTLY THAN CARTEL TRUST
PASSED GROWERS.
THIS UNCERTAINTY UNDERMINES
EVERYTHING THIS LEGISLATURE THE
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA SET IN
MOTION AND ONLY SERVES TO
PERPETUATE THE BLACK MARKET
OPERATORS.
MEANWHILE ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY
WE'RE FIGHTING A VERY REAL OPI
CRISIS THAT IS IN DESPERATE NEED
OF REAL RESOURCES.
NO PRESCRIPTION OPIOIDS ARE
PRESCRIBED EVERY YEAR TO KILL
EVERY CALIFORNIA MORE THAN
TWICE.
THE RESULTS HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATING.
IN THE BOOK IN THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY FOUR MONTH PERIOD BETWEEN
JULY FIFTEENTH. TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN AND AND JULY TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN NINE THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED NINETY CALIFORNIANS
LOST THEIR LIVES AS A RESULT OF
DRUG OVERDOSES.
A TREND PRIMARILY DRIVEN BY
OPIOIDS INCLUDING HEROIN AND
FOUND NO.
PLEASE JOIN CHAIRMAN LOW AND I
AM ASKING ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF
SESSIONS TO FOCUS HIS SIGHTS ON
THE TRUE DRUG CRISIS IN AMERICA.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
ESPECIALLY ASK DRIVER. WOULD YOU
LIKE THE FIRST ROLE TO BE OPEN
FOR COAUTHORS.
MADAM COURT PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS RULES FOR COAL
AUTHORS ON THE JOINT RESOLUTION.
THIS RULE IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE JOINT RESOLUTION.
MADAM CLERK WAS CLOSE THE ROLE
THERE ARE FORTY FOUR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION THIS WILL
REQUIRE A ROLL CALL VOTE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION.
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE ON TELLY THE VOTES.
AYE AYES FORTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
ITEM SEVENTY THREE SEVENTY FIVE
PASS AND RETAIN.
ITEM SEVENTY SIX AB THIRTY ONE
PHONE NINE MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE OH
NINE BY SOME THE MEMBER MARK
STONE AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
CONTRACTS THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THIS BILL DOES TWO
THINGS FIRST WITH RESPECT TO NON
DISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS THAT
EMPLOYEES SIGN. IT WOULD RENDER
VOID THAT PART OF A NON
DISCLOSURE AGREEMENT THAT WOULD
PROHIBIT SOMEONE FROM BEING ABLE
TO TESTIFY. IN A JUDICIAL
ADMINISTRATIVE OR LEGISLATIVE
HEARING WITH RESPECT TO AN
ALLEGED CRIMINAL ACTIVITY OR
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
THE SECOND PARTS WOULD PROHIBIT.
A
NON REHIRE PROVISIONS THAT IF
SOMEONE FOR EXAMPLE.
HAS BEEN HAS.
BLOW THE WHISTLE ON SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IN AN ORGANIZATION
AND AS PART OF THE SETTLEMENT
SIGNS AN AGREEMENT. THAT THAT
PERSON WOULD NO LONGER BE ABLE
TO BE HIRED BACK INTO THAT
AGENCY OR ORGANIZATION WOULD
MAKE OF THAT PROVISION VOID AND
NOT ENFORCEABLE THIS IS TO NOT
ENSURE THAT WE ARE NOT RE
VICTIMIZING. VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND OTHER WITH THE
BLOWING AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT AYE
VOTES.
THANK YOU SEEN IT NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
AROUND.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE TALLY THE VOTES.
I FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM SEVENTY SEVEN SEVEN THROUGH
EIGHTY ONE PASS AND RETAIN
MOVING TO ITEM EIGHTY TWO AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY EIGHT MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINE FIFTY EIGHT BY SOME
A MEMBER QUIRK AND ACTUALLY THE
STATE GOVERNMENT.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS A.
B. TWENTY FIVE NINETY EIGHT.
WOULD ALLOW ADVISORY COMMITTEES
TO MEET VIA TELECONFERENCE
PROVIDED THEY MEET CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS
THESE INCLUDE ADOPTING
GUIDELINES POSTING ONE PHYSICAL
LOCATION WHERE THERE'S A QUORUM.
AND INFORMATION ON HOW THE
PUBLIC CAN PARTICIPATE.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE PROVIDE
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE ON A VARIETY
OF SUBJECTS THEY ARE UNPAID AND
HAVE NO DECISION MAKING
AUTHORITY.
AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY EIGHT HAD
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT THE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU.
SEEING THEIR REQUEST TO SPEAK
NOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
TWO NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM EIGHTY THREE PASS AND
RETAIN.
ITEM EIGHTY FOUR AB TWENTY NINE
EIGHTY MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE EIGHTY
BY SOME A MEMBER GIPSON AND
ACTUALLY THE CANNABIS.
THANK YOU AS A MEMBER GIPSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINE. EIGHTY WHICH SEEKS
TO ENSURE A LOCAL CITIES ON CAN
OPERATE THE SOCIAL EQUITY
PROGRAMS THE LOS ANGELES SOUTH
OF.
THE LOS ANGELES US SO SOCIAL
EQUITY PROGRAM HAS ADOPTED TO
ADDRESS THE NEGATIVE IMPACT ON
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE HEART HAVE
BEEN HARMED BY THE WAR ON DRUGS.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO REVISE THE
DEFINITION OF PREMISE TWO
ALLOWED THE CANNABIS LICENSE TO
BE OCCUPIED IN THE SAME AREA.
THIS CHANGE IS NEEDED IN ORDER
TO ENSURE OF EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
LEGAL CANNABIS INDUSTRY TO
EXPAND OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE
WHO HAVE BEEN HARMED.
A BY THE WAR ON DRUGS
AND THIS IS A MULTI BILLION
DOLLAR INDUSTRY. OF THIS MEASURE
HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT I
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN A DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
RULING TALLY THE VOTES.
EYES FORTY ONE NO SIXTEEN.
THE MOTION PASSES.
ITEMS EIGHTY FIVE THROUGH EIGHTY
SIX PASS AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A VERY SPECIAL
GUEST IN THE CHAMBERS WITH US
TODAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA
RECOGNIZE
THEY GIVE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ARE I
WANT TO INTRODUCE US I'M NOT BE
AT PEACE FROM THE SEVENTY
PERCENT WE DISTRICT.
REDUCED MISTER BRIAN IN HIS
JEANS FOURTH GRADE CLASS OF FROM
MISSION BAY MONTESSORI ACADEMY.
STRAIGHT FROM SAN DIEGO OTHER
UP IN THE GALLERY ABOVE YOU GUYS
WELCOME TO THE CAPITAL OF THE
PLANE WAS A LITTLE TOO LATE BUT
THEY MADE IT WE'RE GLAD THEY'RE
HERE BROWN BECAUSE.
THIS IS A GREAT GUY.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
ITEM EIGHTY SEVEN EASY OUR TO
TWENTY SEVEN MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION TO
A SEVEN BY SOME A MEMBER COOPER
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA'S INFIDEL MONTH.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER
YOUR RECOGNIZE THAT YOU MAY HAVE
SPEAKER MEMBERS IF YOU ARE TWO
TWO SEVEN RECOGNIZED ZINFANDEL
WINE FOR ITS CULTURAL AND
HISTORICAL CONTRIBUTION.
THE CALIFORNIA THAT PROCLAIMS
MAY AS IF IN DEL MONTH.
CALIFORNIA SOME OF THE OLDEST
ZINFANDEL VINEYARDS IN LODI IN
THE FOOTHILLS WITH VINES THAT
ARE OLDER THAN HUNDRED YEARS
INNER STILL PRODUCING EXCELLENT
WINE.
IN FACT THIS WEEKEND IN LODI HIS
THE FOURTEENTH ANNUAL ZEN FAST
ONE FESTIVAL CELEBRATING THIS
AMAZING LINE.
UNFORTUNATELY NEW INCREASED COST
OF LABOR GORE'S ARE PULLING OUT
THE OLD VINES
REPLACING THEM WITH VIA
VARIETALS THEY'RE LESS EXPENSIVE
TO GROW AND HARVEST.
THIS IS RESULTING IN LIVING
HISTORY BEING DESTROYED.
WELL WE ENJOY ALL VARIETALS IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT WE CELEBRATE ALL
VINE ZINFANDEL NOW IN HOPES OF
SHINY LIGHT ON THE PLIGHT. OF
THIS ONE.
CHEERS AND PLEASE GO OUT THIS
WEEKEND AND YOU GLASSES THEN AND
CELEBRATION.
I I RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I RISE TODAY IS CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON
WINE I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ELK GROVE FOR
INTRODUCING ACR TWO TO SEVEN. TO
RECOGNIZE OUR STATE'S WINE GRAPE
GROWERS AND BUT THERE'S FOR
THEIR INCREDIBLE ZINFANDEL
WINDS.
MANY OF US LIKE TO ENJOY A GOOD
GLASS OF WINE BUT WHAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE HOW CALIFORNIA WINE.
IS MORE THAN JUST THE CALL
QUALITY CALIFORNIA WINE INDUSTRY
HAS MADE SIGNIFICANT STRIDES IN
RESEARCH AND SUSTAINABILITY. ALL
ARE CULTIVATING A PRODUCING SOME
OF THE MOST EXCEPTIONAL WINES IN
THE WORLD.
I WANT TO ALSO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE AND
THANK OF MANY FAMILIES BIZ.
THREE.
CALIFORNIANS HAVE SOMETHING TO
BE PROUD OF MEMBERS I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT.
CHEERS.
CHEERS SUMMER EGGMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU GONNA SPEAK
I ALSO GET UP TO. SPEAK IN FAVOR
OF ALL VINES THEN I SHARE THE
ZINFANDEL DISTRICT WITH NE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM HELP GROWTH
THE LODI DISTRICT IS KNOWN FOR
OUR OLD VINES AND. AND MEMBERS
IT'S PARTY HISTORY IN THAT WHEN
WE FIRST CAME TO CALIFORNIA FOR
THE GOLD RUSH EVERYBODY CAME TO
LOOK FOR GOLD BUT THEY DECIDED
PEOPLE NEEDED A DRINK SOME WINE
WHILE THEY WERE LOOKING FOR THAT
GOAL TO. AND SO THEY WERE IT'S
IT'S CALLED THE MYSTERY WHY WE
DON'T KNOW IF THE.
CAME FROM ITALY OR CROATIA BUT
WHEREVER IT CAME FROM IT LANDED
IN THE LODI AREA BEFORE THEY ONE
UP TO THE FOOTHILLS TO FIND THAT
GOLD SO WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
YOUR CUP OF GOLD MEMBERS.
START OFF FOR THE CUP OF RED
WINES IN.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED I TWO WOULD
LIKE TO RISE TO SUPPORT IT WOULD
INVITE YOU ALL THE CINEMA COUNTY
MENDOCINO COUNTY.
CUTS
SOME OF THE GREATEST INFIDEL
YOU'LL EVER TASTE.
A LOT OF IT IS OLD BIND SO I'M.
CHEERS CHEERS TO ADHERE TO AN
AMAZING ONE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON
YOUR RECOGNIZE MEMBERS AND WE
CANNOT FORGET ABOUT SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY AND OUR WONDERFUL
PINOS SO I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
VISIT SANTA BARBARA COUNTY ARE
SATURDAYS VALLEY AND ENJOY A
WONDERFUL PINOS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN THE POINT
OF ORDER.
WHAT IS YOUR POINT OF ORDER BUT
IT WAS ZINFANDEL DAY?
YOUR POINT IS NOT WELL TAKEN.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER WOULD YOU
LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
PLEASE.
MEDICAL PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE. CO
AUTHORS ON THE ZINFANDEL
RESOLUTION.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ON THE ZINFANDEL RESOLUTION.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION.MADAM CLERK
PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE THERE ARE
SIXTY FOUR CO AUTHORS ON THE
ZINFANDEL RESOLUTION.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS ITEM ALL IN
FAVOR PLEASE SIGNIFY BY SAYING
AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
ITEM EIGHTY EIGHT PASS AND
RETAIN ITEM EIGHTY NINE PASS
TEMPORARILY. ITEM AT NINETY AB
TWENTY TO THIRTY MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO THIRTY
BY SOME A MEMBER BERMAN AND
OTHERS AND I KILLINGS ACTIONS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT A BE
TWENTY TO THIRTY WHICH ISN'T
NEARLY AS INTERESTING AS THE
ZINFANDEL RESOLUTION.
BUT IS A BILL TO CREATE TO
SEPARATE STATEMENT RELATED
EFFICIENCIES IN CIVIL
LITIGATION.
ONE COURTS LACK RESOURCES CIVIL
LITIGATION IS AMONG THE FIRST TO
FEEL THE EFFECTS.
THIS BILL IS THE PRODUCT TO
DISCUSSIONS BETWEEN THE
PLAINTIFF AND DEFENSE BAR TWO
PARTIES THAT ARE NOT ALWAYS ON
THE SAME PAGE BUT IS TO BOTH
SUPPORT FINDING EFFICIENCIES TO
BENEFIT THE CIVIL JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW CORDON
DISCOVERY TO HAVE A PARTY SUBMIT
A CONCISE OUTLINED OF ISSUES IN
THE WORK OF ALANIS. VOLUMINOUS
SEPARATE STATEMENT FILING THESE
CHANGES ANOTHER RADICAL NOR
CONTROVERSIAL BUT THEY WILL
PROVIDE HELPFUL STREAMLINING AND
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND HOW THE VOTES.
I SIXTY FOUR AT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM NINETY ONE PASS AND RETAIN.
ITEM NINETY TO A. B. THIRTY TWO
SEVENTEEN MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ SOME LEGAL THIRTY TWO
SEVENTEEN BY SOME MEMBER BERMAN
AND ACTUALLY TO ADVERTISING
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MA'AM SPEAKER.
I RISE TO PRESENT AB THIRTY TWO
SEVENTEEN A BILL TO ADDRESS
MISLEADING ADVERTISING IN THE
LEGAL SECTOR WE'VE ALL OF YOU TO
ADVERTISEMENT ASKING IF YOU'RE
TAKING A PARTICULAR PRESCRIPTION
DRUG. OR HAD AN IMPLANTABLE
MEDICAL DEVICE
THE MESSAGES CAN EASILY LEAD A
PERSON TO WONDER IF THE
MEDICATION PRESCRIBED OR DEVICE
IMPLANTED IS DOING MORE HARM
THAN GOOD.
THIS BILL WOULD EXTEND THE
CONSUMER LEGAL REMEDIES ACT
MATERIAL AND MATERIALLY
MISLEADING ADVERTISEMENTS FOR
LEGAL SERVICES THE BILL WILL
PROVIDE THAT AN ADVERTISEMENT
MAYBE CONSIDER MATERIALLY
MISLEADING. IF IT EITHER
MATERIALLY UNDERSTATES THE
BENEFITS OF A DRUG OR DEVICE OR
MATERIALLY OVERSTATES THE RISK
ASSOCIATED WITH THE DRUG OR
DEVICE ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO THE MOTION
PASSES.
ITEMS NINETY THREE AND NINETY
FOUR PASS AND RETAIN. ITEM
NINETY FIVE AB TWENTY TWELVE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY TWELVE BY SOME THE
MEMBER MEDINA AND ACTUALLY THE
SCHOOLING COMMUNITY COLLEGE
EMPLOYEES ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY TWELVE AB TWENTY
TWELVE WOULD SIMPLY INSURE. THAT
PART TIME FACULTY.
WORKING AND DIFFERENTIAL PAY
DISTRICTS RECEIVE NO LESS.
FIFTY PERCENT OF HIS OR HER
REGULAR SALARY. FOR THE DURATION
OF PARENTAL LEAVE.
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE INSTRUCTORS AND
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES UP TO
TWELVE WEEKS OF DIFFERENTIAL
PAY.
BY PROVIDING THEM WITH THE SAME
PAID PARENTAL LEAVE RIGHTS AS
CERTIFICATED EMPLOYEES.
MEMBERS IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT A CHILD'S HEALTH. AND WELL
BEING IS GREATLY AFFECTED BY THE
PRESENCE OR ABSENCE.
THE CONSISTENT PARENT OR
CAREGIVER.
ESPECIALLY AT THE EARLIEST
STAGES OF THEIR DEVELOPMENT IN
THE FIRST TWELVE WEEKS.
AB TWENTY TWELVE ADDRESSES AND
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE IN
CURRENT LAW I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN OR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
EYES FORTY THREE KNOWS SEVENTEEN
THE MEASURE PASSES.
ITEMS NINETY SIX AND NINETY
SEVEN PASS AND RETAIN I AM
NINETY EIGHT AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY TWO MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GLORIA AND OTHERS ACTUALLY TO
HOUSING SOME MEMBER GLORIA
RECOGNIZED.
THE COMMANDER SPEAKER I RISE
THIS MORNING TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY TWO ALSO
KNOWN AS THE CALIFORNIA
SUSTAINABLE AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ACT. THIS BILL AIMS TO
INCENTIVIZE THE PRODUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE WORKFORCE HOUSING.
ALONG TRANSIT PRIORITY QUARTERS.
THE CASA HOUSING ACT PROVIDES AN
OPT IN FLOOR AREA RATIO BASED
PROGRAM THAT MODIFIES
DEVELOPMENT STANDARDS INCREASES
DENSITY AND MAINTAINS PROJECT
HEIGHTS BE REGULATED BY THE
UNDERLYING BASE ZONING.
IT CREATES NATURALLY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS TWENTY PERCENT OF
WHICH ARE PROPOSED TO BE AT OR
BELOW FIFTY PERCENT AREA MEDIAN
INCOME.
THIS WILL ESSENTIALLY ALLOW FOR
MORE SMALLER UNITS TO BE BUILT
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE UNDER
CURRENT RULES.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY TWO AIMS
TO TACKLE OUR STATE'S GROWING
HOUSING A DEFICIT.
THAT CASA HOUSING ACT A DOES NOT
USE PUBLICLY FUNDED DOLLARS TO
SUBSIDIZE THE FLOOR AREA RATIO
PROGRAM INSTEAD IS A MARKET
DRIVEN APPROACH TO KEEP UNITS
AFFORDABLE WHILE PROVIDING
HOUSING FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS AND WORKING
CALIFORNIANS.
THIS BILL HAS PROVIDED HAD
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
CERTAINLY DESERVE YOUR VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
EYES FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM NINETY NINE THROUGH ONE OH
ONE PASS AND RETAIN.
ITEM ONE KNOW TO A BE TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY FIVE ON THE
AMENDMENTS MATTER QUICKLY THREE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY FIVE WITH AMENDMENTS BY
SOME A MEMBER RODRIGUEZ.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RODRIGUEZ YOU
RECOGNIZE MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY FIVE MAKES CHANGES. TO
THE CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE PROJECT
AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL AND AT
COAUTHORS A RESPECTFULLY
OUTRIGHT VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN A REQUEST TO
SPEAK IF THERE ARE NO OBJECTIONS
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY
SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
BILL IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE.
ITEM ONE NO THREE AB THIRTY TO
FIFTY FOUR MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TO FIFTY
FOUR WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY ARE
RECOGNIZED MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB THIRTY TO FIFTY FOUR IS THE
ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE'S ANNUAL OMNIBUS BILL.
WHICH MAKES MINOR AND NON
CONTROVERSIAL CHANGES TO THE
LEFT OR LAW THESE AMENDMENTS
MAKE TECHNICAL CLARIFYING
CHANGES THAT HAVE BEEN REVIEWED
AND APPROVED BY NUMEROUS
STAKEHOLDERS. I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
BILL IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE. ITEM ONE OH FOR ACR ONE
SEVENTY FOUR MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE SEVENTY FOUR BY
FAMILY MEMBER GIPSON BELTED TO
HEPATITIS AWARENESS MONTH AND
HEPATITIS TESTING DAY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TO
PRESENT ACR ONE SEVENTY FOUR
WHICH PROCLAIMS MAY AS HEPATITIS
AWARENESS MONTH AND MAY
NINETEENTH IS HEPATITIS TESTING
DAY. BETTER PREVENTION DETECTION
AND TREATMENT HEPATITIS
INFECTION IS CRITICAL TO ADDRESS
RELATED DISEASES SUCH AS LIVER
CANCER. WE'VE SEEN RECENTLY
HEPATITIS CAN DEVASTATE AN
ENTIRE COMMUNITY AND THAT THOSE.
HAVE LESS ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE
ARE THE MOST VULNERABLE THIS
MEASURE IS MEANT TO BRING
AWARENESS TO EDUCATE AROUND
HEPATITIS INFECTIONS I WERE
ASKED. OF THE FIRST REAL THE
ROLE BE OPEN BOOK AUTHORS
RESPECT WE ASK THAT AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING THAT NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MEDICAL
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE FOR COOPER.
MEMBERS THIS ROLE IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
MEMBERS MISTER GIBSON IS
REQUESTING CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE.
THERE ARE SIXTY TWO CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE SAY
AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
I DON'T WANT NO SIX AND ONE OH
FIVE PASS AND RETAIN ITEM ONE OH
SEVEN ACR TO THIRTY THREE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TO THIRTY
THREE BY THREE MEMBER REYES AND
OTHERS ABILITY TO RAMADAN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAY AS YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT ACR TWO THIRTY THREE. A
RESOLUTION THAT ACKNOWLEDGES THE
MUSLIM HOLY MONTH OF RAMADAN AND
EXPRESS THE LEGISLATURE'S
RESPECT.
TO MUSLIMS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
YESTERDAY WAS THE FIRST FULL DAY
OF THE ISLAMIC HOLY MONTH OF
RAMADAN WHICH REQUIRES MUSLIMS
TRIPS FAME FROM FOOD OR DRINK
FROM SUNRISE TO SUNSET. EVERY
DAY FOR THIRTY DAYS.
RAMADAN IS A TIME FOR REFLECTION
AND SPIRITUAL DISCIPLINE FOR
MUSLIMS AROUND THE WORLD. WHEN
THEY EXPRESS OUR DEVOTION TO
FAITH.
FAMILY AND SERVICE TO THE LESS
FORTUNATE.
THE MUSLIM AMERICAN COMMUNITY
CONTINUES TO BE A PILLAR OF
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE CITY.
ENCOMPASSING NEARLY EVERY ETHNIC
GROUP OF OUR STATE.
THE RICH DIVERSITY OF THE
COMMUNITY HAS THROUGHOUT ITS
HISTORY PLACED MUSLIM AMERICANS
AT THE FOREFRONT A SOME OF OUR
MOST PRESSING SOCIAL ISSUES.
CONSIDERING THAT HATE CRIMES
AGAINST MUSLIM AMERICANS HAVE
GONE UP EXPONENTIALLY IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS. WITH THE RISE OF
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN ALONE.
IT IS IMPERATIVE NOW MORE THAN
EVER THAT WE AS A BODY TAKEN
ACTIVE STAND.
A CELEBRATE THE MUSLIM COMMUNITY
AND CONTINUE TO AFFIRM AND
DEFEND THEIR PLACE IN AMERICAN
SOCIETY.
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE RELIGIOUS
COMMUNITIES EMBODY OUR INHERENT
VALUES AS A STATE.
AND AS A COUNTRY.
AS DOES OUR COMMIT COMMITMENT TO
RESPECT.
EQUALITY AND PEACE AMONG
CULTURES.
MEMBERS I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
ON ACR TWO THIRTY THREE SO THAT
WE CAN COLLECTIVELY WISH OUR
MUSLIM FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS. A
BLAST RAMADAN I WOULD LIKE THE
FIRST ROLE TO BE OPEN FOR
COAUTHORS.
THANK YOU. MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE
YOUR ATTENTION TO A SOME MEMBER
WEBER.
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS.
AND SUPPORTIVE ACR TWO THIRTY
THREE AND THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAY AS FOR BRINGING THIS
RELEVANT AND HOLY RARE
REMEMBRANCE TO THE CELEBRATION.
ARE ON THIS FLOOR. I WANT EXTEND
MY BEST WISHES TO MUSLIMS IN
CALIFORNIA AND AROUND THE WORLD
HAPPY RAMADAN.
RAMADAN IS THE MONTH IN WHICH
MUSLIMS BELIEVE THE KORAN WAS
REVEALED TO THE PROPHET MUHAMMAD
BEGINNING WITH A SIMPLE WORD.
IQRA.
WHICH MEANS READ.
WITH A SIMPLE YET POWERFUL
PHRASE THE FAITH OF ISLAM
UNDERSCORES THE IMPORTANCE OF
GAINING KNOWLEDGE TO BRING LIGHT
INTO OUR HEARTS AND COMMUNITIES.
RAMADAN THERE FOR THE TIME WHEN
MUSLIMS REFLECT UPON THE WISDOM
THE GUIDANCE THE INTERNAL AND
EXTERNAL PEACE THAT COMES FROM
FAITH. AND RESPONSIBILITY OF
HUMAN BEINGS HAVE TO ONE ONE
ANOTHER AND TO GOD.
LIKE MANY PEOPLE OF DIFFERENT
FAITHS WHO HAVE SEEN RAMADAN
THROUGH THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
FAMILIES I KNOW THIS IS A
FESTIVE TIME FOR THEM.
A TIME WHEN FAMILIES GATHER IN
BILLS THIS YEAR AND THEY FOCUS
UPON THEIR FAITH IN THEIR
BELIEF.
THESE RITUALS REMIND US OF THE
PRINCIPLES THAT ALL OF US HOLD
IN COMMON.
IN ISLAM ROLE IN ADVANCING
JUSTICE PROGRESS TOLERANCE AND
THE DIGNITY OF ALL HUMAN BEINGS.
RAMADAN REMINDS OF THE RICHNESS
BOZEMAN'S ADD TO THE RELIGIOUS
TAPESTRY OF AMERICAN LIFE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
WE'RE ALL BLESSED TO LIVE UNDER
A CONSTITUTION OF FOSTER'S
RELIGIOUS LIBERTY AND RESPECTS
RELIGIOUS PRACTICE.
OUR CONSTITUTION ENSURES THAT
MUSLIMS CAN OBSERVE RAMADAN IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THEIR CONSCIENCE
AND UNDER AN UNHINDERED BY
GOVERNMENT.
BUT JUST LIKE MANY IN OUR
MINORITY COMMUNITIES MUSLIMS IN
THE UNITED STATES FACE
DISCRIMINATION.
PACIFIC LIKE A KNOWN AS
ISLAMOPHOBIA AND IT IS UP TO US
TO ENSURE THAT WE UPHOLD OUR
CONSTITUTION.
PROTECT THEIR RELIGIOUS LIBERTY
IN RIGHTS
AND OF LIFT THEIR VOICE IN
STORIES.
NATIONALLY RUINS OF MUSLIMS HAVE
A LONG HISTORY IN THE UNITED
STATES
SPANNING BACK TO THE SLAVE
TRADE.
AND WHICH TEN TO FIFTEEN PERCENT
OF ALL THOSE WHO WERE ENSLAVED
MEN AND WOMEN. WERE OF THE
MUSLIM FAITH.
WE SHOULD NEVER FORGET THIS
ROUTE THAT WAS IMPORTANT IN
DEVELOPING THIS NATION.
THE CONCEPT OF FREEDOM AND
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE ARE ROOTED
IN THE AT OF THE MUSLIMS THAT WE
HAVE. AND WE SHOULD NEVER ALLOW
THEM TO BE MARGINALIZED OTHER
RISE TO FEDERAL POLICIES AND TO
ANTI MUSLIM RHETORIC.
THERE ARE ONE POINT SIX BILLION
MUSLIMS WORLDWIDE.
AND CALIFORNIA'S HOME TO
APPROXIMATELY ONE MILLION.
MUSLIM AMERICANS FROM DIVERSE
ETHNIC AND CULTURAL BACKGROUNDS
THEIR PRESENCE IN THE STATE AND
NATION IN RICHES OUR COMMUNITIES
AND WE ARE STRONGER AS A STATE
BECAUSE OF IT.
IT IS INTERESTING THAT WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT RELIGION WE OFTEN
THINK ABOUT THE DIVISION THAT
EXIST BETWEEN INDIVIDUALS.
AND THERE BEEN WARS FOUGHT MORE
WARS FOUGHT ABOUT RELIGION THAN
ANYTHING ELSE.
AND YET WHEN WE STUDY AND
UNDERSTAND THE PRINCIPLES OF
MOST RELIGIONS THEY'RE BASICALLY
THE SAME PRINCIPLES THAT MOST OF
US BELIEVE THEM.
FAMILY LOVE THE COMMUNITY
HELPING EACH OTHER REACHING OUT
AND TRYING TO BUILD A BETTER
WORLD. AND YET WE SOMETIMES GET
CAUGHT UP IN THE DIVISION AND
THE DIFFERENCES RATHER THAN THE
THE THINGS THAT BIND US
TOGETHER.
SO HOPEFULLY AS WE THINK ABOUT
OUR MUSLIM BROTHERS AND SISTERS
FASTING DURING RAMADAN A TIME
WHEN THEY FAST IN ORDER TO
UNDERSTAND WHO THEY ARE TO GET
TO THE PRINCIPLES THAT THEY
BELIEVE IN. AND ALSO TO
STRENGTHEN THEIR THEIR PRACTICE
OF FAITH. AND THEIR TOLERANCE
AND INVOLVEMENT WE STAND AND WE
WISH THE MUSLIMS OF CALIFORNIA
BEST WISHES ON RAMADAN. WE HOPE
THEY WILL HAVE AN EARLY EVENING
BARRACK WHICH MEANS A HAPPY
WOULD END DOING WAS ENDING
OF THE CELEBRATION OF THEIR
FAITH.
DURING THIS MONTH OF RAMADAN
AND ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS AND
MILLIONS OF MILLIONS OF OUT OF
AFRICAN AMERICANS WHO ARE
MUSLIMS IN THIS COUNTRY. WHO
CAME TO THIS COUNTRY AS MUSLIM
WHO HAVE ADAPTED SOMETIMES TO
SOME CHRISTIAN FAITH WILL
CONTINUE TO HOLD ON TO THE
MUSLIM IDEOLOGY? WE SAY HAPPY OF
RAMADAN AND WE SHOULD I REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT FOR ACR TO THIRTY
THREE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LOOK
YOU KNOW LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AND
IS A PROUD JOINT AUTHOR OF ACR
TO THIRTY THREE.
I'M PROUD TO BE HERE TODAY AND
JOIN OUR FELLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FROM SAN BERNARDINO. AND WANT TO
THANK HER FOR BRING THIS
HISTORIC RESOLUTION TO OUR
FLOOR.
WE ARE HERE TODAY TO CELEBRATE
THE EMBARK MENT OF MANY OF OUR
CALIFORNIANS.
WHO ARE GOING THROUGH THIRTY
DAYS OF FASTING?
REFLECTING OF RAMADAN.
THE MONTH OF RAMADAN IS A TIME
WHEN MUSLIMS ALL OVER THE WORLD
AND RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
ABSTAIN FROM FOOD AND OR DRINK
DURING THE LIFE HOURS.
TO THE MUSLIM COMMUNITIES THIS
MONTH IS SO MUCH MORE THAN JUST
GIVING UP FOOD AND DRINK.
IT IS A TIME OF TOGETHERNESS.
WITH EACH OTHER THAT STRENGTHENS
THE TIES OF THEIR FAMILIES AND
FRIENDS.
IT'S A TIME OF SPIRITUAL
NOURISHMENT.
THROUGH SELF REFLECTION AND
THROUGH PRAYER.
AND IT IS A TIME TO PRACTICE
COMPASSION. FOR EVERYONE AND
EVERYTHING.
RAMADAN FOSTERS A BEAUTIFUL
BALANCE
BETWEEN SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY
AND SELF KNOWLEDGE.
MUSLIMS ARE ENCOURAGED TO SPEND
TIME IN SELF RESPECT XIN. BUT
ALSO TO BE PRESENT FOR ONE
ANOTHER.
IT IS A PROFOUND EXERCISE IN
REALIZING THAT STRONG
COMMUNITIES FIRST AND FOREMOST
DEPEND ON SELF ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND THAT THERE IS NO SELF
WITHOUT RESPONSIBILITY TO
OTHERS.
THESE ARE THE VALUES THAT I HOLD
DEAR.
AND REMIND ME OF THE SHARED
VALUES MANY OF US PRACTICE.
AND IT IS.
I AM PROUD.
TO BE UP LIFTING THEM AND
CELEBRATING THEM TODAY THROUGH
THIS RESOLUTION.
RAMADAN REMINDS US THAT CERTAIN
INDIVIDUALS AND POWERS MAY TRY
TO CREATE DIVISIONS WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITIES BY FOSTERING FEAR
AND HATRED.
OUR CORBELL USE
OF HUMANITY.
PEACE EQUITY AND JUSTICE ARE THE
SAME REGARDLESS OF OUR FAITH.
AND THAT OUR DIFFERENCES ONLY
MAKE US STRONGER AS A STATE.
AS A NATION AND AS A PEOPLE.
I WAS HONORED TO ATTEND THE
MUSLIM COMMUNITIES FOURTH ANNUAL
IFTAR THAT THEY HAD LAST YEAR.
AND WITNESSED A BEAUTIFUL
GATHERING OF WHICH WE BROKE
BREAD TOGETHER AT SUNSET.
IT WAS A JOYOUS OCCASION OF
UNITY.
THAT I AM LOOKING FORWARD TO
JOINING AND CO HOSTING THE
FIFTEENTH ANNUAL CELEBRATION
NEXT WEEK.
I RISE TODAY TO WISH ARE MUSLIM
COMMUNITY A VERY HAPPY RAMADAN.
MAY THIS BE A MONTH FILLED WITH
PEACE AND BLESSINGS FOR
EVERYONE.
AND MAYBE YOU HAVE A CELEBRATE
TERRY EVEN.
TO COME.
I WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT AC ARE
TWO THIRTY THREE AND URGE YOU
ALL TO SUPPORT AND WISH OUR
FELLOW MUSLIM COMMUNITY MEMBERS
A HOPLEY HAPPY RAMADAN.
RAMADAN MUBARAK.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES AS.
CHAIR OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF ACR TO THIRTY
THREE. THE MONTH OF RAMADAN IS
OF INCREDIBLE SIGNIFICANCE FOR
MUSLIMS AROUND THE WORLD IT IS A
MONTH WHICH CONSISTS OF FASTING
FROM SUNRISE TO SUNSET. EVERYDAY
FOR ABOUT A MONTH
THIS MONTH IS ALSO INCREDIBLY
FOCUSED ON COMMUNITY. ORIENTED
EVENTS SUCH AS LARGE COMMUNITY
DINNER SPEEDING OF THE HOMELESS
ACTS OF COMMUNITY SERVICE AND
VOLUNTEERISM AND DONATING TO
CHARITY. THERE ARE WELL OVER ONE
MILLION MUSLIMS IN CALIFORNIA
ALONE COMING FROM. I DIVERSE
ARRAY OF ETHNIC BACKGROUNDS
CALIFORNIA'S HOST.
TOO MANY MUSLIM AMERICANS WHO
HELP FROM EVERY PART OF ASIA.
INCLUDING INDIA PAKISTAN
INDONESIA MALAYSIA AND CHINA I
WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS MEASURE FORWARD
ASPECT WE ASK YOU AYE VOTE ON
ACR TO THIRTY THREE.
THANK YOU SING KNOWN FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MEADOW PARK
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE FOR
COAUTHORS.
MEMBERS THIS RULES FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE. THERE ARE SIXTY CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
ITEMS ONE TWO EIGHT THREE ONE
SIXTEEN PASS AND RETAIN WE'RE
MOVING BACKWARDS AND FILE ORDER
TO ITEM EIGHTY NINE AB TWENTY
TWO NINETEEN MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO
NINETEEN BY FAMILY MEMBER TING
ACTUALLY LIEUTENANCY THANK YOU
SO MEMBER TING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB TWENTY TWO NINETEEN
ISSUES ARE RENT PAYMENTS. CAN BE
MADE BY A THIRD PARTY OTHER THAN
THE TEN IT WITH THE WRITTEN
NOTICE UPS BUT
PROTECTIONS FOR A LANDLORD.
I'M CARRYING THIS BILL BECAUSE
CLEARLY.
GIVEN OUR HOME WITH THIS CRISIS
ONE OF THE BEST WAYS TO KEEP
PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS.
IS TO ENSURE THAT THEY GET THE
HELP PAYING THE RENT TO KEEP ME
IN THEIR HOMES ARE WOULD BE ABLE
TO REMOVE.
MOST OF THE OPPOSITION.
WITH THIS BILL PASSED OUT OF
JUDICIARY TEN ZERO AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MEADOW PARK WAS OPEN THE
WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
I SIXTY TWO NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING BACK TO FILE ORDER.
ITEM ONE EIGHTEEN SCR ONE THIRTY
SEVEN METAPHOR PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
THIRTY SEVEN BY SENATOR LARA AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO FOSTER CARE
MONTH.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
I SEE ARE ONE THIRTY SEVEN
DESIGNATES THE MONTH OF MAY AS
NATIONAL FOSTER CARE MONTH IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THIS
YEAR I SEE ARE ONE THIRTY SEVEN
ALSO RECOGNIZES THE
EXTRAORDINARY ROLE THAT LGBTQ
PARENTS PLAY IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM.
AS WELL AS THE UNIQUE CHALLENGES
FOR CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER YOUTH
WHO HAPPENED TO BE LGBTQ.
FOSTER CARE MONTH HAS BEEN
OBSERVED ACROSS THIS NATION
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT AND
IS BROAD AND BROUGHT MUCH NEEDED
ATTENTION TO THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES OF OUR FOSTER YOUTH.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN MEMBERS THERE
ARE OVER FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SEVEN THOUSAND YOUTH LIVING IN
FOSTER CARE NATIONWIDE WITH
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
MANY OF THESE YOUTH HAVE ENDURED
YEARS OF ABUSE AND NEGLECT
AND THEY OVER THEY DON'T WE
CANNOT OVERCOME THAT IN JUST ONE
MONTH. IT TAKES YEARS OF
COMMITMENT BY MANY MANY PEOPLE
INCLUDING THOSE OUR COURT SYSTEM
OUR SCHOOLS ARE NONPROFIT SECTOR
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY ALL OF
YOU IN THE LEGISLATURE AND EX OF
COURSE THE EXTRAORDINARY FOSTER
PARENTS. AND FAMILY MEMBERS.
MEMBERS CALIFORNIA IS A NATIONAL
LEADER IN PROTECTING THE RIGHTS
IN FIGHTING FOR THE FEATURES OF
OUR FOSTER YOU. NO MATTER WHO
THEY ARE BY THEIR RACE THEIR
GENDER OR THEIR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION.
CALIFORNIA'S LGBTQ YOUTH ARE
UNFORTUNATELY OVER REPRESENTED
IN OUR STATES FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM.
TWENTY FOURTEEN STUDY OF FOSTER
YOUTH IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
FOUND THAT NINETEEN PERCENT OF
FOSTER YOUTH.
OVER THE AGE OF TWELVE
IDENTIFIED AS LGBT Q. AND THAT
PERCENTAGE OF LGBTQ YOUTH IN
FOSTER CARE IS UP TO TWICE THAT.
OF LGBTQ YOUTH WHO ARE NOT IN
FOSTER CARE.
MANY OF THESE CHILDREN
EXPERIENCE FURTHER TRAUMA
STEMMING FROM THE FAMILY
REJECTION MISTREATMENT AND
SCHOOL BULLYING DUE TO THEIR
SEXUAL ORIENTATION GENDER
IDENTITY OR GENDER EXPRESSION.
THE CALIFORNIA IS ONE AMONG THE
FEW STATES THE NATION THAT X.
WITH EXPLICIT NONDISCRIMINATION
PROTECTIONS IN STATUTE TO
PROTECT THESE YOUNG PEOPLE AND
THEIR CAREGIVERS.
LGBTQ FAMILIES HAVE STEPPED UP
AS ADOPTIVE AND FOSTER PARENTS
OFTEN HEALED THESE VULNERABLE
YOUNG PEOPLE.
S. C. ARE ONE THIRTY SEVEN
PROCLAIMS MAY AS NAS NATIONAL
FOSTER CARE MONTH IT CALLS UPON
ALL CALIFORNIANS TO STRENGTHEN
OUR COLLECTIVE EFFORTS TO ENSURE
THE STABILITY AND IMPROVED
OUTCOMES OF LGBT Q. FOSTER
YOUTH.
IN CALIFORNIA MEMBERS ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR LARA I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE THOSE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. ARE YOU REQUESTING CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
YES MA'AM SPEAKER THANK YOU
METACARPALS OPEN THE ROLE.
OFFERS.
MEMBERS THIS ROLE IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLES FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE FIFTY ONE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY SAYING
AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WE ARE MOVING NOW TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING ON THE CLERK
WILL READ THE SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR. AT SOME LEVEL TWENTY
FIVE FIFTY NINE BY SOME THE
MEMBER TING ACTUALLY TO
ELECTIONS.
THANK YOU ALL THOSE ADEQUATE
PLEASE OPEN THE RUN TIME
CALENDAR.
ALL THOSE VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL THOSE VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MEDICARE PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES.
I SEVENTY NO ZERO THE CONDUCT
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE READING OF
THE REMAINING ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CALENDAR WILL
BE DEFERRED UNTIL THE END OF
SESSION.
WE'RE MOVING NOW TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS.
MEMBERS.
PLEASE.
JOIN ME AND NOT WISHING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JOAQUIN ARAMBULA A VERY
HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
MEMBERS BUDGET SUB.
FOR WILL BE MEETING DIRECTLY
AFTER REESE
AFTER A GERMAN IN ROOM FOUR
FORTY SEVEN.
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
FRIDAY MAY EIGHTEENTH NO FLOOR
SESSION NO CHECK IN SESSION
MONDAY MAY TWENTY FIRST FLOOR
SESSION AT ONE PM.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
FORM CALL IS LIFTED WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR MOVE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR.
FOR OUR ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY.
MA'AM SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES.
WITH A HEAVY HEART.
DID I ADJOURNED IN MEMORY TODAY.
OF CHAIRMAN JOHN JAMES OF THE
CABAZON BAND OF MISSION INDIANS
WHO PASSED AWAY PEACEFULLY.
MONKS HIS FAMILY AND FRIENDS ON
APRIL TWENTY FIRST OF THIS YEAR.
CHAIRMAN JAMES WAS ONE OF THE
MOST RECOGNIZED AND RESPECTED
NATIVE AMERICAN LEADERS.
THROUGHOUT THE U. S. AND HAS
BEEN CALLED THE FATHER OF NATIVE
AMERICAN GAMING.
BUT TO THE CABAZON BAND HE WAS
SIMPLY.
CHAIRMAN.
BORN IN NINETEEN THIRTY ONE
CHAIRMAN JAMES WAS A KOREAN WAR
VETERAN.
SERVING AS A MEMBER OF THE
WOLFHOUNDS TWENTY SEVENTH
INFANTRY REGIMENT.
AND THE TWENTY FIFTH INFANTRY
DIVISION.
HE RECEIVED TWO BRONZE STARS AND
WAS RECOGNIZED BY PRESIDENT
NIXON AS AN HONORARY NAVAJO CODE
TALKER.
HE BECAME SECRETARY TREASURER OF
THE CABAZON BAND MISSION INDIANS
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN HAS GOT
MORE INVOLVED WITH THE TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT. HE RECOGNIZE THE
NEED FOR TRIBAL SELF
SUFFICIENCY.
HE SAW THE ESTABLISHMENT OF HIGH
STAKES BINGO AND POKER AS A
MEANS OF ACHIEVING THAT GOAL.
HE WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN GUIDING
THE TRIBE AS IT MADE ITS WAY
THROUGH THE COURT SYSTEM.
LEADING TO THE LANDMARK NINETEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN CABS ON DECISION IN
THE U. S. SUPREME COURT
AFFIRMING THE INHERENT RIGHT. OF
THE CABAZON BAND OF MISSION
INDIANS AND OTHER SOVEREIGN
TRIBES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
TO SET THE COURSE FOR THEIR OWN
FUTURES AND CONSEQUENTLY.
CREATING THE INDIAN GAMING
INDUSTRY IN THE UNITED STATES.
CHAIRMAN JOHN JAMES WAS ELECTED
INTO OFFICE AS CHAIRMAN OF THE
CABAZON BAND OF MISSION INDIANS.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE AND
SERVED IN THAT POSITION FOR MORE
THAN TWENTY YEARS.
CABS ON BAD ACKNOWLEDGES HIM AS
A LEADER WHO PERSEVERED THROUGH
MANY CHALLENGES. AND WAS OFTEN
VICTORIOUS ALL WHILE FIGHTING
FOR THE RIGHTS OF ITS PEOPLE.
A RECIPIENT OF MANY HONORS CHAIR
CHAIRMAN JAMES WAS AWARDED WITH
THE NATIONAL INDIAN GAMING
ASSOCIATION FUNKY FOR
SOVEREIGNTY AWARD.
RECOGNIZING HIS WORK TOWARD THE
PROTECTION OF INDIAN SOVEREIGN
RIGHTS.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTY WAS AWARDED
THE PATH BREAKERS AWARD BY THE
INDIAN GAMING REGULATORY ACT.
CONFERENCE RECOGNIZING HIS
EFFORTS TO RESTORE TRIBAL
SUFFICIENCY.
AND RESPECT FOR TRIBAL
SOVEREIGNTY.
HE WAS ALSO HONORED WITH A
PLAQUE IN TWO THOUSAND STEAM IN
MY HOMETOWN.
THE CITY OF COACHELLA AT THE
VETERAN'S MEMORIAL OPENING
CELEBRATION.
CHAIRMAN JOHN ALEXANDER JAMES IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE.
TWO CHILDREN TWO STEPDAUGHTERS
ELEVEN GRAND CHILDREN PLAY TWO
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN AN EXTENSIVE
TRIBAL FAMILY THAT REACH BEYOND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA'S I'D LIKE
TO CONCLUDE.
MAN SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES BY
SAYING THAT THIS INDIVIDUAL NOT
ONLY LEAD THE WAY.
TO TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY
S. ELEVATING IT IN THIS COUNTRY
AND AGAIN REAFFIRMING THE
SOVEREIGN RIGHT TO INDIAN
GAMING.
BUT BACK HOME.
AN AMAZING PARTNER TO THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
AND RECOGNIZING THE NEED TO
COLLABORATE. AND COORDINATE
EFFORTS TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY
LIFE FOR EVERYONE IN OUR REGION.
ON A PERSONAL NOTE I'D LIKE TO
THANK.
THE CHAIRMAN.
AND THE CABAZON BAND OF MISSION
INDIANS FAMILY WHO GAVE ME AN
OPPORTUNITY WHEN I WAS TWENTY
FOUR YEARS OLD. TO DO AN
INTERNSHIP IN THE GOVERNOR
AFFAIRS DEPARTMENT WHICH TAUGHT
ME ABOUT TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY. AND
ALLOWED ME TO ESTABLISH THOSE
TYPES OF WORKING RELATIONSHIPS.
WITH OUR SOVEREIGN NATIONS
THERE IN MY HOMETOWN. AS I TOOK
THE POSITION OF MAYOR A VERY
GRATEFUL.
TO THE TRIBE AND CERTAINLY
GRATEFUL TO THE CHAIRMAN'S
LEADERSHIP AND THE IMPACT THAT
IT'S HAD NOT ONLY IN INDIAN
COUNTRY BUT IN.
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES
HE WILL BE MISSED BUT CERTAINLY
NOT FORGOTTEN.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ARE
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO
ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF A SAN
FRANCISCAN WHO WAS AN INCREDIBLE
CHAMPION. AND A LEADER FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS FOR PUBLIC SAFETY AND OUR
LEGAL COMMUNITY AND OUR LGBT
COMMUNITY. AND SOMEONE WHO WAS A
FRIEND.
JULIE'S TURMAN.
JULIUS WAS A BRILLIANT LAWYER HE
WAS A PARTNER AT ONE OF OUR
LEADING EMPLOYMENT LAW FIRMS IN
OUR CITY. THROUGHOUT HIS CAREER
HE CHAMPION DIVERSITY IN HIRING
AND IN LEADERSHIP POSITIONS.
IN ADDITION TO HIS LEGAL CAREER
HE ALSO WAS A DISTINGUISHED
PUBLIC SERVANT IN OUR CITY.
HE SERVED ON OUR SAN FRANCISCO
HUMAN RIGHTS COMMISSION.
HE ALSO SERVED ON THE SAN
FRANCISCO POLICE COMMISSION.
AND SERVE THAT COMMISSION AS ITS
PRESIDENT FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS.
WHILE SERVING IN THE POLICE
COMMISSION HE WORKED ON POLICE
REFORM AND POLICIES THAT HELP TO
REWRITE OUR CITIES USE OF FORCE
AND BODY CAMERA POLICIES.
IN ADDITION TO HIS WORK FOR THE
CITY. JULIUS WAS A PROUD MEMBER
OVER LGBT COMMUNITY WAS ACTIVE.
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY AS A STRONG
VOICE AS A CO CHAIR FOR THE BAY
AREA LAWYERS FOR INDIVIDUAL
FREEDOM. AS WELL AS CHAIR FOR
THE LGBT DEMOCRATIC CLUB THE
ALICE B. TOKLAS CLUB.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT HE
SERVED AS THE GRAND MARSHAL OF
OUR SAN FRANCISCO PRIDE PARADE.
THROUGHOUT HIS ENTIRE LIFE
JULIUS WAS AN INCREDIBLE
ADVOCATE FOR ALL PEOPLE AND ALL
SAN FRANCISCANS.
ALL OF US WHO WERE HONORED TO
KNOW HIM.
WILL MISS HIM DEARLY WE WILL
MISS HIS INTELLECT.
WE WILL MISS IS ADVOCACY WE WILL
MISS IS FRIENDSHIP.
JULIUS REST IN PEACE.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
THE DESTINY PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL.
ALL REQUEST WITH YOUR MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL. AS PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED THE REMAINING ITEMS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WILL BE
READ AT THE END OF SESSION.
ALL ARE UP ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASS AND
RETAIN A MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING IN HERE THERE
AND HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS
I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
TO ADJOURN MISTER MELT MULLIN
MOVES AND MISTER BLOOM SECONDS
THAT THE HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL MONDAY MAY TWENTY FIRST AT
ONE PM
.
NEVER HEARD
CLICK OVER THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX SIXTY
FIVE I SEVENTY KNOWS YOU'RE
UNABLE TWENTY THIRTY FIVE I
SEVENTY KNOWS HEROES IN THE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE FIFTY
ONE I SEVEN YOU KNOW ZERO UNABLE
SEVENTEEN FORTY FOUR. I SEVENTY
KNOWS RELIABLE SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
SIX I SEVENTY KNOWS ILLEGAL
SEVENTEEN NINETY AYE SEVENTY
KNOWS YOU'RE UNABLE NINETEEN
THIRTY AYE SEVENTY KNOWS YOU'RE
UNABLE NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN I
SEVENTY NO ZERO SUM ABOUT TWENTY
TWENTY SIX I SEVENTY NO ZERO
SYMBOL TWENTY SIXTY EIGHT BY
SEVENTY NO ZERO ASSEMBLE TWENTY.
WANTED TO I SEVENTY NO ZERO
CYCLE TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN I
SEVENTY NOSAIR'S UNABLE TWENTY
ONE FIFTEEN MY SEVENTY KNOWS
YOU'RE UNABLE TWENTY ONE THIRTY
FOUR I SEVENTY KNOWS THERE'S A
LEGAL TWENTY TWENTY FIVE I
SEVENTY NO SIR SYMBOLS NINETY
FORTY EIGHT I. SEVENTY KNOWS
YOU'RE UNABLE TO NINETEEN
EIGHTY.
TWO I SEVENTY KNOWS ARE UNABLE
TO NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX I SEVENTY
KNOWS YOU'RE A SINGLE TWENTY
THREE NINETY SIX I SEVENTY KNOWS
I'M ABLE TWENTY FOUR ELEVEN AYE
SEVENTY KNOWS ILLEGAL TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY EIGHT. I SEVENTY
KNOWS ILLEGALLY FOR FIFTY SIX I
SEVENTY KNOWS YOU'RE UNABLE
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY EIGHT BY
SEVENTY KNOWS IS A MILITANT
ABOUT SIXTY FOUR I SEVENTY NO
SON IT WAS MY SIXTEEN NINE I
SEVENTY NOSEWHEEL TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY FIVE. I SEVENTY KNOWS IS
A MULTI SIX NINETY FOUR I
SEVENTY KNOWS A MULTI SEVEN
SEVENTEEN I SEVENTY KNOWS YOUR
CLIMATE CHANGE AND A THIRTY FOUR
I SEVENTY KNOWS I'M ULTIMATUM
FIFTY THREE I SEVENTY NO SOME OF
MY SEVEN SIXTY NINE I SEVENTY NO
ZERO SUBTLETY SEVENTY THREE. I
SEVENTY KNOWS YOU'RE LEVEL
TWENTY EIGHTY AYE SEVENTY KNOWS
ABOUT TWENTY EIGHTY FOUR I
SEVENTY KNOWS A LITTLE TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY NINE WITH URGENCY.
I SEVENTY NO ZERO. AND I SEVENTY
KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE URGENCY.
IT'S A NIELSEN ANTI EIGHT I
SEVENTY NO ZERO NOTES WHEN I
TWENTY NINE I SEVENTY NO ZERO
MELTING AND FORTY ONE I SEVENTY
KNOWS THERE'S A MULTI NINE SIXTY
EIGHT I SEVENTY NO
SIMULTANEOUSLY THREE I SEVEN IN
THOSE YEARS I MOSTLY NINE EIGHTY
SIX I SEVENTY NO SIMPLE TWENTY.
NINE NINETY FOUR I SEVEN
INNOCENT ALSO THIRTIES WHILE I
SEVENTY KNOWS YOU'RE SINGLE
THIRTY THIRTY TWO I SEVENTY
KNOWS A LITTLE THIRTY ONE TWENTY
SIX I SEVENTY KNOWS IS ONLY
ABOUT THIRTY ONE FORTY THREE I
SEVENTY KNOWS I'M A THIRTY ONE
SEVENTY THREE AYE SEVENTY KNOWS
THE MILITARY ONCE. EVERY SEVEN
BY SEVENTY KNOWS I'M A THIRTY
ONE NINETY TWO AYE SEVENTY KNOWS
I'M NOT THIRTY FIFTY ONE.
I SEVENTY NO ZERO ASSEMBLED
THIRTY FIFTY TWO I SEVENTY KNOWS
ABOUT THE EIGHTEEN FIFTY FIVE I
SEVENTY NOTABLY BUT THEY TO
FIFTY EIGHT ICE.
MY MOTHER TO SIXTY I SEVEN A NO
SIMPLE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SIX I
SEVENTY NO SINGLE POINT SIX TEN
I SEVENTY KNOWS ABLE SEVENTEEN
NINETY FOUR I SEVENTY KNOWS IS
ABLE TWENTY EIGHT NINETY EIGHT I
SEVENTY KNOWS YOUR SYMBOL THIRTY
TO SIXTY TWO AYE SEVENTY NO
SIMPLE THIRTY TO SIXTY. THREE
AYE SEVENTY NOSING OUT THERE DO
YOU
SUPPORT BY SEVENTY KNOWS
ANYTHING KERN RESOLUTION ONE
SEVENTEEN I SEVEN INDOSIAR
THANKING HER RESOLUTION ONE
TWENTY THREE BY SEVENTY KNOWS
YOUR UNCLE FOURTEEN NINETY SIX
WITH URGENCY. AYE SEVENTY NO
ZERO ON THE MEASURE I SEVENTY
KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE URGENCY
SYMBOL FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
WITH URGENCY I SEVENTY. DOES
ZERO ON THE MEASURE I SEVENTY NO
ZERO ON THE URGENCY AND SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN NINETY NINE I
SEVENTY NO ZERO